melissa was referring to the the famous
your yeah
the coat the coat you've got a steel
you've got to steal it i don't know
that's
that's that damn chambray outfit and i
literally i was like oh my god i gotta
get a turtleneck
i remember thinking like i have to get a
turtleneck and a trench coat
yeah which is like a very short
mid western woman shouldn't i'd like to
see you rock that i think that could be
yeah and do you remember because this
wasn't exactly
the most produced music video of all
time we basically i turned up with a
bunch of clothes in a bag
um i literally you know yeah they're all
my clothes it wasn't styled it wasn't
that what that was
that was an accident it wasn't you know
premeditated or anything
and um there was a guy actually when we
recorded not that far from me we
recorded the video
and um there was a guy doing nights as
we call it he's working through the
night yeah
and he just kept shouting out his window
will you shut that
is this really meant to happen on your
video but yeah so it was kind of a bit
unprepared yeah
and but now tragedy strikes because
that trench coat should be in some sort
of planet hollywood or
uh you know some sort of hall of fame
your closet
on my back where is it
i actually i i did an outside broadcast
in in northern ireland back in the day
right in the beginning of all of that
and a bunch of kids basically as i was
kind of trying
trying to be on the radio i kind of just
pulled it off my back and it just
drifted across
a crowd of like a few hundred maybe a
thousand people and just drifted off
into the sunset that should be a
documentary
that is such a good idea
[Applause]
trademark
but every now and again i kind of see it
coming back to me because we were doing
a gig not too long ago and i saw this
this guy in a trench coat and then sure
enough
as the gig got towards the end and we
hadn't played that song yet it kind of
he took it off and it just kind of
drifted across the crowd to me so i had
to put it on kind of thing so we just
kind of relived the moment together and
i did this was it the right size that's
all um it was a bit big to be honest
i smiled it out you know what i mean
yeah and and we've talked about this
before on the radio and everything this
phenomenon of the
the the rick rolling yeah yeah and i
wasn't going to bring it up
but while you're over there i okay
i didn't want to is that do you want to
talk about that
because i just was wondering if anyone
else had ever gotten rick rolled
uh i i'm yeah that's an interesting
point i mean
these guys haven't they hadn't and they
didn't know what it was
i want to be rickrolled
[Laughter]
it's really it's a very fun situation
but i don't know how you feel
no i've been absolutely fine with it um
we have a daughter and she's 26 years
old now and when that kind of started
about 10 years ago
she literally sat me down on the couch
and said you do realize it's got nothing
to do with you
no and and yeah and i kind of thought
she's absolutely right it doesn't it's
just a song somebody chose
and therefore to do this prank with kind
of thing so therefore it
it i don't own it anymore it's nothing
to do with me this is something else
it's stopped now though it's stopped it
doesn't it stop but it keep people keep
doing things with that tune on the
internet
so what so what happens emma for people
who don't know you open an email
so you open an email and there's a link
to something and it's like oh click this
link and then you click
and then um basically rick a bunch of
pop-ups come up and then his
face it comes up as well and then it
sings never going to give you up
and then until you restart your computer
it doesn't stop
and some people find that funny
turn off your computer and start it up
you